the conference those liberal British
values
are also why I am so angry with this
conservative government
they just don't get her
I'm angry at the way these conservatives
have squandered the hard work and
sacrifices of the British people
as families and pensioners businesses
and workers have all spent the last year
battling soaring energy bills Rising
food prices and the long shadow of the
pandemic
the conservatives have indulged in
damaging party infighting and dangerous
ideological experiments
pig-headed and pie-eyed as my dad would
have said
and I'm not just talking about Boris
Johnson or Liz truss or Rishi sunak
I'm talking about every single
conservative MP at every step of the way
putting their own narrow self-interest
above our national interest
foreign
the conservatives always so out of touch
always taking people for granted what a
disgrace they are
just at a time of crisis when we did
need strong and stable government
the conservatives gave us chaos and
Division
when Britain needed integrity
they gave us Boris Johnson
when our country needed wise leadership
they gave us this trust
when people needed change they gave us
more of the same with Rishi sunak
when we needed a gallant crew on the
bridge to stare to steer our Great
British ship through choppy Waters
we've instead had a bunch of mutinous
pirates only interested in who got to
wear the captain's hat
we needed Hornblower
they gave us pug wash
[Applause]
friends this is going to sound
revolutionary
bear with me
when the country faces a cost of living
crisis I believe the role of government
should be to help people and help
businesses properly
not make it worse
but apparently these conservatives don't
see it that way
their cost of living crisis has plunged
a million more people into poverty many
of them children
tens of thousands of families have been
made homeless
many more families are relying on food
banks
including some of the hardest working
people in our country
as last week's budget confirmed people
are seeing their living standards
plummet at a faster rate than ever
before
and the conservice answer
point a new Deputy chairman to tell
people to stop whining
to tell them they get by on 30p a meal
it's not just the conservatives are out
of touch they are on another planet
[Applause]
just look at the policy choices these
conservatives have made over the last
year while Millions have struggled
taxed properly the record profits of the
oil and gas giants as liberal Democrats
were the first to argue
profits made on the back of Putin's
illegal invasion of Ukraine it's a no
from Rishi sunak
money out of the pockets of struggling
families with unfair income tax Rises
and enthusiastic yes from the
conservatives
start to cut energy bills as gas prices
fall as we proposed
so families and pensioners don't have to
choose between Heating and eating
no way says Jeremy Hunt
but recklessly add hundreds of pounds to
people's monthly mortgage bills pushing
many to the brink of losing their homes
with pleasure as they all gleefully
cheered Liz truss's budget
the conservatives aren't serving the
public
they are only serving themselves
utterly devoid of the values that make
our country so great compassion
Community fairness
these are touchstones for the British
people they are fundamental to us as
liberal Democrats
but they are alien to today's
conservative party
conference I don't believe there is much
that is guaranteed in British politics
any longer
but there is one rule that I think is
set in stone
and that's how you know when a
government has reached the end of the
road
here it is
you can call it David's first law of
politics if you like
and it's this
you know a government has reached the
end of the road when it chooses to pick
a fight with match of the day
thank you
if they didn't think it was all over
before
certainly do now
[Applause]